Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“追求经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。节目由Marianne Trent博士主持。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and thank you for listening or if you're on YouTube, thank you for watching. So today is episode 44 and it was supposed to be episode 43 which would have been rather magic except for life doesn't always run smoothly. So why it would have been super duper magic to have today be episode 43 is because the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book is now available. And that includes 43 individual personal accounts and reflections from aspiring psychologists. So it's like it was like meant to be. It would have been a happy accident. But actually, we do have more than 43 accounts in there because one of the contributors asked loads of people in her department to also write little snippet accounts and top tips and advice as well. So we've got loads more than 43 in there. But yes, a new baby has been born, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. And I'm so excited and so pleased that it's been here.
嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是Marianne Trent博士，感谢大家的收听，如果你是在YouTube上观看，也感谢你的观看。今天是第44期节目，原本应该是第43期，那会非常神奇，但生活总是不尽如人意。之所以说今天如果是第43期会超级神奇，是因为《有抱负的心理学家集体》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）这本书现在出版了。书中包含了43位有抱负的心理学家的个人经历和反思。所以这就像是命中注定一样，本会是一个美丽的巧合。但实际上，书中的故事远不止43个，因为其中一位投稿人邀请了她部门里的许多人也写了小片段、小贴士和建议。所以书里的内容比43个要多得多。总之，一个新的“宝宝”诞生了，那就是《有抱负的心理学家集体》。我非常兴奋，也很高兴它终于面世了。
And it's not been an easy process. So if you are watching on YouTube, you might be like, Marianne looks a bit rough today. I've got a horrid old cold. I was definitely squeezing my schedule more than I usually would, which meant less sleep, less kind of, less recharge time and I think as a result my children's lurgies which always kind of float around the edge having young children have finally come and snaffled me so I would hope that I'm on the way, on the way up out of it now but I said that as I said that I like a little bit of a sneeze in the back of my nose um I'm hoping I'm well and truly on the mend and by tomorrow I can be my usual perky slightly irritating myself um yeah so I've cancelled personal training this week just because I think
这个过程并不容易。如果你在YouTube上观看，你可能会觉得Marianne今天看起来有点憔悴。我得了严重的感冒。我最近的日程安排比平时更紧凑，这意味着睡眠减少，充电时间减少。我想结果就是，我孩子们身上总是带着的那些小病菌——家里有小孩总是这样——终于传染给我了。我希望我现在正在好转，但刚才说话时我感觉鼻子里又有点痒，想打喷嚏。嗯，我希望我真的在康复中，到明天又能恢复我平时那种活泼、甚至有点让人烦的自己。嗯，是的，我取消了这周的私人健身课程，因为我觉得
that's maybe not the the kindest thing I could be doing to myself when I'm not feeling well. So a bit of rest and recharge, some time to record podcasts and edit podcasts and look after myself. So let me tell you a little bit about this wonderful book and the people within it. So if you've previously caught the Clinical Psychologist Collective book and you enjoyed it, then I'm going to say 100% guaranteed that you are going to also enjoy the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. If you've never heard of either, then I'll just give you a little bit of background about what the books are and specifically what this new book is. So both books, in fact, the Grief Collective book as well, are what's called autoethnography. So they are people's words, reflective accounts, talking about their own life experiences and kind of things they've experienced along the way.
在身体不适的时候，这可能不是对自己最好的照顾方式。所以，休息和充电，花点时间录制和剪辑播客，照顾好自己。让我来给你们介绍一下这本精彩的书以及书中的人们。如果你之前看过《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书并喜欢它，那么我敢保证，你也一定会喜欢《有抱负的心理学家集体》。如果你两本书都没听说过，那我就简单介绍一下这两本书的背景，特别是这本新书。事实上，这两本书，还有《悲伤集体》（Grief Collective）这本书，都是所谓的“自动民族志”。它们是人们用自己的文字写下的反思性叙述，讲述了他们自己的生活经历以及一路走来所经历的事情。
They are wonderful to read if you're looking to improve your own skills as an aspiring psychologist in reflection and in kind of thinking about your own story and how you've grown over time. They're also really, really good for giving you ideas about how you could, you know, approach your career in a way that might help you get your foot in the door or, you know, get where you want to be or have ideas about jobs or roles to apply for. So that's certainly feedback that I've had about things that people have really enjoyed about the clinical psychologist collective book but I recognized that getting on training you know when you read the clinical psychologist collective getting on training feels like it's then inevitable because even though it was tricky you know everybody managed it and so I wanted to just introduce you to a stage before
如果你想作为一名有抱负的心理学家提高自己的反思能力，思考自己的故事以及随着时间的推移如何成长，那么阅读这些书是非常棒的。它们也非常适合为你提供思路，让你了解如何以一种可能帮助你敲开大门的方式来规划职业生涯，或者让你知道如何到达你想去的地方，或者为你提供申请工作或职位的灵感。这确实是我从人们对《临床心理学家集体》的反馈中听到的，大家真的很喜欢这些内容。但我意识到，当你阅读《临床心理学家集体》时，你会觉得进入培训课程似乎是必然的，因为尽管过程很棘手，但每个人都成功了。所以我只是想向你介绍一个更早的阶段，
that so within the aspiring psychologist collective spoiler alert there are some trainings or now trainings that probably weren't trainings when they wrote their accounts because they got on to training during this most recent season. But there are also people who are yet to apply for professional psychology routes. There are also people who did apply and weren't successful and kind of found out quite close to the wire that they weren't being offered places. And so it's kind of like a roller coaster real life ride through professional psychology not just clinical psychology but I would say probably 95% is clinical psychology so there's some PhD in there and some educational psychology I don't think we've got any counselling or forensic that I can think about I feel like I know the stories quite well and I don't think
那就是在《有抱负的心理学家集体》中——剧透预警——有一些人现在已经进入了培训，尽管他们在写这些故事时可能还没进入，因为他们是在最近这一季才被录取的。但书中也有人尚未申请专业心理学途径。还有人申请了但没有成功，在最后一刻才得知没有被录取。所以这就像是专业心理学领域的一场过山车般的真实旅程，不仅仅是临床心理学，但我可以说大概95%是临床心理学，其中也包含一些博士研究和教育心理学。我想不出有任何咨询或法医心理学的内容，我觉得我对这些故事很熟悉，我不认为
we've got that um in in the stories um unless it's one of the ones that was submitted quite early and I therefore signed off on a long time ago so i'm sorry if you're listening to this and you're like i am i made it and she didn't mention me i'm really sorry but trying to juggle 43 stories as well as all of the publishing demands um has been tricky um but yeah so grateful for everybody who is within the aspiring psychologist collective and they will all be getting a contributor copy as well but you can now grab your copy there's a link in the show notes for how to do that um and it is via amazon but um yeah check the show notes or check um any details on my my social media for a direct link to the right book.
我们有这些内容，除非是那些很早就提交并被我很久以前签收的故事。所以，如果你正在听这段话并想说“我成功了，但她没提到我”，我真的很抱歉。但要同时处理43个故事以及所有的出版需求确实很棘手。不过，我非常感谢《有抱负的心理学家集体》中的每一个人，他们都会收到一本投稿人样书。现在你们可以去买书了，节目说明里有链接，是通过亚马逊购买的。请查看节目说明，或查看我社交媒体上的任何详细信息，以获取正确书籍的直接链接。
So let's have a little bit of a think about some of the themes in the book. So one of the themes is most definitely self-care and reducing burnout. And also with a lovely sprinkling of compassion in there too we've got a foreword in this book for the first time ever by Dr Chris Irons who's also a clinical psychologist and writes lots of lovely books on self-compassion and compassion focused therapy and the benefits for ourselves and our clients about introducing that into our world so thank you very much Chris I will be sending you a copy to say a big thank you as well but yeah the idea of other aspiring psychologists almost talking to you in many cases in their accounts about how to remain compassionate to
那么，让我们来思考一下书中的一些主题。其中一个主题绝对是自我关怀和减少职业倦怠。书中还融入了慈悲的元素。我们第一次邀请到了Chris Irons博士为本书作序，他也是一位临床心理学家，写过许多关于自我慈悲和慈悲焦点疗法的优秀书籍，以及将这些理念引入我们的世界对我们自己和客户的好处。所以非常感谢Chris，我会寄给你一本作为大大的感谢。但确实，书中许多有抱负的心理学家在他们的叙述中都在谈论如何保持对他人的慈悲，
yourself and how to not burn out on the way to where you want to be is absolutely running throughout the stories within all of the collective I would say. It kind of feels like soul food for psychologists, I think. It's not your average book. It's not a textbook. It's just a really nice connected experience where you feel like part of the process and you're rooting for people in their own journeys as well. So that's theme one, I would say. Theme two is that people have been really honest about their own impact and their own mental health journeys along the way, either as a result of kind of stresses and strains of the job, or due to kind of non-job related things as well so I know often I get asked questions you know should I disclose about any mental health history that I've had and this
以及如何在通往目标的道路上避免倦怠，这绝对贯穿了整个集体中的所有故事。我觉得这就像是心理学家的心灵食粮。它不是普通的书，也不是教科书。它是一种非常美好的连接体验，让你感觉自己是这个过程的一部分，并且也在为人们的旅程加油打气。所以这是第一个主题。第二个主题是，人们非常诚实地谈论了他们自己的影响以及一路走来的心理健康历程，无论是由于工作的压力和紧张，还是由于与工作无关的事情。我知道经常有人问我：“我应该披露我曾经的心理健康史吗？”而这
kind of book will give you really useful insights for how people are thinking about it and talking about it and how they're actually you know quite proud about their experiences in the sense they've made of it and how, in fact, all of this reflecting and all of this growth and change and, you know, difficulties they've had along the way makes them a better psychologist and not a worse one. So if you're looking for top tips about how to think about that for your own professional psychology career, then I'd say this book is going to be especially wonderful for you too. If you've been listening to the podcast for a while, you will know that I love a jingle. So it's no surprise that I also have a jingle for the new book, baby. So let you be the very first people to hear it. And I will catch up with you on the other side of that.
种书会为你提供非常有用的见解，让你了解人们是如何思考和谈论它的，以及他们实际上是如何为自己的经历感到自豪的——因为他们理解了这些经历，事实上，所有这些反思、成长、变化以及一路走来遇到的困难，都使他们成为了一名更好的心理学家，而不是更差的。所以，如果你正在寻找关于如何为自己的专业心理学职业生涯思考这些问题的建议，那么我会说这本书对你来说也会特别棒。如果你听这个播客有一段时间了，你就会知道我喜欢叮当声。所以，为这本新书“宝宝”准备一个叮当声也就不足为奇了。让我让你们成为第一批听到它的人。听完之后我们再聊。
I hope you enjoy it. So many tips and lessons to learn from. So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. oh my days if you didn't find that rousing are you even breathing um you know oh jingle guy you're just so talented like oh just love it. The first version of that was also marvellous. But I was like, Paul, because that's his name. I love it. And I love Christmas as much as the next person. And I love sleigh bells. But I think the sleigh bells might make it sound a little bit too Christmassy. And this book, this book, baby, is a book bit too christmasy and this book this book baby
希望你喜欢。有太多的技巧和经验可以学习。有太多的事情你可以尝试。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。天哪，如果你觉得这不够振奋人心，那你还在呼吸吗？哦，叮当声制作人，你真是太有才了，我太喜欢了。第一个版本也很棒。但我当时说：“Paul，因为那是他的名字，我喜欢它。”我像其他人一样喜欢圣诞节，也喜欢雪橇铃声。但我认为雪橇铃声可能会让它听起来有点太像圣诞节了。而这本书，这本书，宝贝，是一本
is a book for all seasons it's not just a book for the winter christmas season so could we maybe not have the christmasy one but maybe i should do the christmasy one around christmas so you can hear this sleigh bell version so perhaps I've ended up getting two jingles for the price of one I'll have to give you a bit more money Paul um but yeah I love that like I just imagine you in your kitchens or your showers or out walking your dogs like just yeah being uplifted and you know energized so energized. So yeah, I really like that. The Clinical Psychologist Collective book is a bit more mellow-y, isn't it? But this one is like, yeah, guys, we've got it. We are on it. We are on this mission. So yeah, absolutely thrilled with that and hope you like
适合所有季节的书，不仅仅是冬天的圣诞季节。所以我们能不能不要那个圣诞版本？也许我应该在圣诞节前后用那个圣诞版本，这样你就能听到那个带雪橇铃声的版本了。所以也许我最终以一个价格得到了两个叮当声。我得给Paul多付点钱。但我喜欢这样，我能想象你们在厨房里、淋浴时，或者遛狗时，感到振奋和充满活力。是的，我真的很喜欢。那本《临床心理学家集体》稍微柔和一点，对吧？但这一本就像是：“伙计们，我们做到了。我们正在行动。我们正在执行这个任务。”所以，我对此感到非常激动，希望你们也喜欢
it. Feedback about Jingles is gratefully received. You may have noticed there's no audio testimonials yet because this book baby is so brand new that we don't have any. However, however, there is your chance to feature in audio testimonials but also help yourself at the same time. So there's going to be information in the show notes about how you, yes, you can leave me an audio testimonial. So what is going to be happening is we've got a little competition running until midnight on Halloween 2022. so the 31st of October 2022. So as not to exclude people that have bought the Clinical Psychologist Collective book recently, if you have bought either book between the 1st of September and then midnight 31st of October 2022. And you send me your unique proof of purchase.
它。非常欢迎大家对叮当声提出反馈。你们可能已经注意到还没有音频推荐，因为这个书宝宝太新了，我们还没有。但是，你们有机会参与音频推荐，同时也能帮助自己。节目说明里会有关于你——是的，就是你——如何给我留下音频推荐的信息。我们将举办一个小比赛，截止日期是2022年万圣节午夜，也就是2022年10月31日。为了不排除最近购买了《临床心理学家集体》的人，如果你在2022年9月1日至10月31日午夜之间购买了这两本书中的任何一本，并把你的唯一购买凭证发给我，
So please don't use someone else's. Your unique proof of purchase for either or both books. You can get an entry to win a one-to-one coaching session with me. And the coaching sessions will be happening on the first, second or third of November. So if you can't do that day, you might want to think about perhaps not entering, but we could do daytime or we could do evening one of those days. So yeah, you can get your chance to then talk with me about your psychology career and if you've got a professional psychology application we can use that time together to go through that together to think about really strengthening it and making it have more bang for your buck but if you're not applying this year
所以请不要使用别人的。你购买其中一本或两本书的唯一凭证。你就可以获得一次赢取与我一对一辅导的机会。辅导课程将在11月1日、2日或3日进行。所以如果你那天没空，你可能需要考虑一下是否参加，但我们可以在那几天的白天或晚上进行。所以，你可以有机会和我谈谈你的心理学职业生涯，如果你有专业心理学申请，我们可以利用这段时间一起梳理，思考如何真正加强它，让它更有成效。但如果你今年不申请，
we can use that session to really think about professional skills and, you know, your next step. Or if you're qualified already and you'd welcome using that session for, you know, professional coaching, for thinking about your way forward for stuff that might not just be one-to-one therapy, then please do submit your proof of purchase as well. But because we were speaking about audio testimonials, you can also get a bonus point by recording me an audio testimonial for either book. And there's a way you can do that that I will drop in the show notes and also pop out with my socials as well. Yes, because it's great to be able to demonstrate real readers and what they think to the book. So please do take a moment to do that.
我们可以利用那次会议来真正思考专业技能和你的下一步。或者如果你已经具备了资格，并且欢迎利用那次会议进行专业辅导，思考你除了一对一治疗之外的前进方向，那么也请提交你的购买凭证。但因为我们刚才在谈论音频推荐，你还可以通过为任何一本书录制音频推荐来获得额外积分。有一种方法可以做到这一点，我会把它放在节目说明里，也会在我的社交媒体上发布。是的，因为能够展示真实的读者以及他们对书的看法是很棒的。所以请花点时间去做这件事。
And when you submit your testimonial, if it's usable, no swearing in it, and it's audible, etc. Then I will give you a bonus point, a bonus entry into that prize draw. And if you want to do one for both books, you can get two bonus entries. And then last but not least, if you leave me a verified purchase review for either or both books, you can also get bonus points, bonus entries. So here's your chance to get one, two, three, four, five, potentially six entries to get a one to one with me. If you only wanted one book, then you can just do that related to one book. But if you've already read the Clinical Psychologist Collective and would like to leave me a testimonial for that, please do that as well.
当你提交你的推荐时，如果它是可用的（没有脏话，声音清晰等），那么我会给你一个额外积分，作为抽奖的额外入场券。如果你想为两本书都做推荐，你可以获得两个额外入场券。最后但同样重要的是，如果你为任何一本书或两本书留下了经过验证的购买评论，你也可以获得额外积分和额外入场券。所以这是你获得一次、两次、三次、四次、五次，甚至六次与我一对一交流机会的机会。如果你只想要一本书，那么你只需要做与那本书相关的事情。但如果你已经读过《临床心理学家集体》并想为它留下推荐，也请这样做。
Because it's really lovely to be able to demonstrate. People love it, you know, people are really, really benefiting from the content within that. So yes, please do, please do do that. All right. So let's get back on to some of the themes for the new book, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. Just looking at my list there, because I did write myself a little prompt list this time, because I do usually freestyle for these episodes, but the old brains aren't working so well right now,
因为能够展示出来真的很棒。人们喜欢它，人们确实从书中的内容中受益匪浅。所以是的，请务必这样做。好了，让我们回到新书《有抱负的心理学家集体》的一些主题上来。看看我的清单，因为这次我确实给自己写了一个提示清单，因为我通常在这些节目中是即兴发挥的，但我的大脑现在运转得不太好，
because they're just being a bit sleep deprived and a little bit muggy headed. OK, so another theme which has developed really wonderfully within the APC, as we've been calling it when we've been publishing, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, is that people are offering their top tips to you throughout, you know. And that's just really really great um you know ways that you can think oh yeah I could totally do that um that's a bit of me you know I yeah that really resonates with me so um yeah dive on in and discover those top tips for yourself and when I was growing up, I was always taught, we mustn't draw in books, Marianne. It's very bad, very bad behavior. But there are some books that
因为睡眠不足，头脑有点昏沉。好的，那么在APC（我们出版时一直这样称呼它，《有抱负的心理学家集体》）中发展出来的另一个非常棒的主题是，人们在整个过程中都在为你提供他们的顶级建议。这真的非常棒，你可以想：“哦，是的，我完全可以那样做，那很适合我。”是的，这真的引起了我的共鸣。所以，深入其中，为你自己发现那些顶级建议吧。当我长大的时候，我总是被教导：“Marianne，我们不能在书上乱画。这是非常糟糕的行为。”但有些书，
I have bent the rules for over my time. And I've got highlighters out and, you know, I've added little sticky memos to pages that I knew I'd want to come back for and I would definitely say that this book the aspiring psychologist collective is a kind of book that you can bend the rules for you can get your highlighters out and you can stick stickers in and help this be really bespoke to you and you can write in it bits that resonate with you or spark ideas so this becomes almost your own personal reflections as well as that of that of the contributors as well and another theme is collaboration it really feels like a collaborative effort I know when I was an aspiring psychologist it very much felt like it was each man or each woman for themselves.
我确实打破了规则。我拿出了荧光笔，在我想回看的页面上贴了小贴纸。我绝对会说《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书就是那种你可以打破规则的书。你可以拿出荧光笔，贴上贴纸，让它真正为你量身定制。你可以在上面写下引起你共鸣或激发你灵感的片段，这样它就变成了你自己的个人反思，以及投稿人的反思。另一个主题是协作。它真的感觉像是一次协作努力。我知道当我还是一个有抱负的心理学家时，感觉非常像是每个人都在为自己奋斗。
And I think that it feels different to that these days. It feels like people really want you to succeed as well. They don't want to keep all these secrets to themselves. And by the very nature of all of the free content I've been producing with this podcast, with the Q&As and with the feedback that I've been getting with this podcast, with the Q&As, and with the feedback that I've been getting from people as well, is just how refreshing it is to have this content put out there by a qualified psychologist, someone that's giving such useful, tangible, actionable advice, and, you know, is demonstrating this stuff is working you know it's working for people within my world it's working for people people are watching the q a's
我觉得现在感觉不一样了。感觉人们真的也希望你成功。他们不想把这些秘密都留给自己。通过我这个播客制作的所有免费内容，以及问答环节，还有我从人们那里得到的反馈，我发现由一位合格的心理学家发布这些内容是多么令人耳目一新。有人给出了如此有用、具体、可操作的建议，并且在展示这些东西是有效的。你知道，它在我的世界里对人们有效，它对人们有效，人们在观看问答环节，
they're trying my tips and then they're messaging me to say oh that was really helpful that really worked i really got some good stuff there um so please um if you're enjoying what I'm doing do consider leaving me a review on Apple podcasts would be wonderful so if you click on library which is at the bottom of your podcast app and then click on shows and hopefully you're following me already and then click on the aspiring psychologist collective and then scroll down a little bit where it says episodes and then currently the bottom of episode 36 but it would depend when you're watching this is one that says trailer and then below trailer we've got ratings and reviews so if you've got just one moment just click hopefully Hopefully a five star review would be great. But if you've got a little while longer, just click the see all. You can't really see. Click the see all next to ratings and reviews.
他们尝试我的建议，然后给我发信息说：“哦，那真的很有帮助，真的很有用，我从中学到了很多好东西。”所以，如果你喜欢我所做的事情，请考虑在Apple Podcasts上给我留下评论，那将非常棒。所以，如果你点击播客应用底部的“资料库”，然后点击“节目”，希望你已经关注了我，然后点击《有抱负的心理学家集体》，然后向下滚动一点，在“剧集”下方，目前第36集的底部（取决于你什么时候看），有一个写着“预告片”的，在预告片下方，我们有评分和评论。所以如果你有一点时间，就点击一下。希望五星好评会很棒。但如果你有更多时间，只需点击“查看全部”。你可能看不见，点击评分和评论旁边的“查看全部”。
And then the option there is write a review. So that would be really, really wonderful. I've had one most recently given me today. not today, Tuesday. So I haven't seen this one yet. So this is breaking news. Let me read this to you. Thank you, Marianne, for sharing and recording these podcasts. They're an excellent resource full of helpful, compassionate and insightful experiences and reflections, which are useful when we're navigating the twisty world of clinical psychology. These topics are core to working in the field of psychology and highlight the importance of self-compassion along your journey in and outside of psychology. I love that. Thank you so much. So, yes, the ratings and reviews really help us to demonstrate that what we're doing is useful.
然后选项是“撰写评论”。那将真的、真的非常棒。我最近收到了一条，不是今天，是周二。所以我还没看过这一条。所以这是突发新闻。让我读给你听。“谢谢Marianne分享和录制这些播客。它们是一个极好的资源，充满了有益、富有同情心和深刻的经验与反思，在我们探索临床心理学这个复杂世界时非常有用。这些主题是心理学领域工作的核心，并强调了在心理学内外旅程中自我关怀的重要性。”我喜欢这个。非常感谢。所以，是的，评分和评论确实帮助我们证明我们所做的事情是有用的。
And then when shows have more ratings and reviews they get shown more readily to other people so they help us further that collaborative nature so you know if you don't want to buy anything if you don't want to leave me any reviews please at least follow or subscribe because that helps me know that you are valuing what you're getting from us. So, yeah, the themes of the book are just wonderful. And this time we have pictures and things in the book as well. So not photographs as such, but just different kind of infographics, different things to read just to break up the text a bit and to kind of um yeah help you yeah
当节目有更多的评分和评论时，它们会更容易被展示给其他人，所以它们帮助我们进一步推动这种协作性质。所以，如果你不想买任何东西，如果你不想给我留下任何评论，请至少关注或订阅，因为这让我知道你正在重视从我们这里得到的东西。所以，是的，书中的主题真是太棒了。而且这次书中还有图片和各种东西。不是照片，而是不同种类的图表，不同的阅读内容，只是为了打破文字的沉闷，并以某种方式……是的，帮助你……是的，
help it feel like a really nice read um and it's yet to be finalized but the plan is um the the hardback is going to be available in full color as well um it was on my to-do list um to get that sorted um but i don't feel very well um so this week has been a little bit different than what was expected um but there yes within the book there is also an exclusive download for you um for thinking about how to um really understand the declensi um application season um giving you top tips as well. So, yeah, grab your copy. Come on in. Don't forget about that contest, that competition, which is closing midnight on Halloween, 31st of October.
帮助它感觉像是一本非常好的读物。虽然还没最终定稿，但计划是精装版也将提供全彩版本。把它整理好在我的待办事项清单上，但我感觉不太舒服，所以这周和预期的有点不同。但是的，书中还有一个独家下载内容，供你思考如何真正理解申请季，并为你提供顶级建议。所以，去买一本吧。加入我们。别忘了那个比赛，截止日期是万圣节，10月31日午夜。
Please do come along and join us in the Facebook group as well, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Collective. That group is building nicely. We only launched that probably a month or so ago um but yeah come on over be part of my world also please let me know what you like next what would be useful for you in the podcast um i aim for this to be really useful stuff for you so yes um it's it's here it's my next book baby and it's the one that I think I am proudest of yet um just because it's really lovely really lovely and I think it's that that's me on the back on a good good day. It's that collaborative nature, which feels so useful. And I think because if you're reading this as an aspiring psychologist or an aspiring mental health professional, it's just going to be talking to you where you're at right
也请加入我们的Facebook群组，即《有抱负的心理学家集体》。那个群组发展得很好。我们大概一个月前才启动它，但是的，过来成为我世界的一部分吧。也请告诉我你接下来喜欢什么，什么对你来说是有用的。我旨在让这些内容对你真正有用。所以是的，它就在这里，这是我的下一个书宝宝，也是我认为目前为止我最引以为傲的一本。只是因为它真的很可爱，真的很可爱。我想这就是我在状态好时所能做到的。那种协作的性质感觉非常有用。我想因为如果你作为一名有抱负的心理学家或有抱负的心理健康专业人士阅读它，它会直接与你现在的处境对话，
now. And so it's going to be wonderfully validating and normalizing and nourishing so I hope you really enjoy it I can't wait and also I'm a little bit nervous to see what people think of it I hope that you really like it as much as I do and as much as my proofreader has done as well be kind and yeah let me know what you think but yes until then until i hear from you um i will look forward to catching up with you on our next episode which is going to be landing with you 6 a.m on monday um but yeah thank you very much enjoy this exit jingle um and yeah if you want to listen back to the rousing aspiring psychologist collective jingle
所以它会非常令人肯定、正常化和滋养。所以我希望你真的喜欢它。我迫不及待了，而且我也有一点紧张，想看看人们对它的看法。我希望你像我一样喜欢它，也像我的校对员一样喜欢它。请保持友善，让我知道你的想法。但在此之前，直到我收到你的消息，我期待在下一期节目中与你见面，节目将于周一早上6点发布。但是的，非常感谢，享受这个结束的叮当声。如果你想回听那个振奋人心的《有抱负的心理学家集体》叮当声，
um please do um but yeah catch up with you soon thank you so much for being part of my world bye if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Duret. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and
请务必回听。很快再见，非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。再见。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你就会走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》。主持人是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Yana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同故事的内容非常有趣，
how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及人们是如何成为临床心理学家的。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。